si bien alors on va vous aider adamo oui
mais comme on a aidé damas montiel tout
à l'air parce qu'il fait un pas c'est
une émission altruiste oui donc on va
vous aider finalement il ya déjà eu donc
renaud letang tous à cette tentative
d'arriver dans la chanson française la
plus actuelle de radiohead à madame reno
les toits au monde alors on va faire une
interview relooking
on va changer notre image alors on va
changer votre image est ce que vous
pourriez dire comme ça maintenant
regardons vous êtes un obsédé sexuel
mais je sais depuis l'automne vous êtes
un obsédé sexuel à moi oui c'est vrai
que j'ai essayé de le cacher que final
voilà c'est transparaît voilà paraître
et combien de femmes avez vous eu à
d'amour dans votre vie aux trois par
jour depuis 40 ans et où est ce qu'on
voit là vous avez pas un scoop sur votre
jeunesse un truc horrible un peu de
pédophilie un truc un peu sulfureux côté
pédophilie non ça ne m'était pas cette
chanson là j'ai lu un jour dans un
journal italien
un article sur la princesse paola est un
peu la belle c'était tellement bien le
chantier rhodiole terkel que je viens de
joie c'est le lycée c'est le fils de
baudoin qui était si vaste et monsieur
alors par la wii rue donc il ya eu 7 se
délient mais sur le fond les délires de
trois dames ou la coiffure se serait pas
mieux de nous faire un petit un petit
saut du lit peut-être cet accord ouais
djia est ce que vous pouvez faire un duo
avec un crétin issus de la star ac
quand même talent qui sait gazole à la
semaine prochaine je vais faire un duo
avec nolwenn et c'est indéniable et le
calcaire là c'est ce que je voulais
savoir je le fais la semaine prochaine
avec les gamins salvatore sérieusement
et là c'est important pour votre image
votre bouche tu chocolat oui mais aussi
est-ce que c'est un combat dia cousin au
japon oui oui mais normalement c'est
laisser les phalanges comme où et quand
on est pris en défaut un mois c'était la
bouche il me pressait semelle rouge la
foule lui rappellera qu'en regard dany
l'a fait
là aussi le côté naturel et sauvage bien
non sérieusement adamo et là c'est très
important c'est juste pour relooker
votre ménage pour voir un petit peu plus
rebelle à percy adamo un racing
mon fils est ce que vous seriez j'ai un
ami qui s'est fait percer l'anus par un
autre très bon ami à moi
et bah ça s'est bien passé comme quoi
allez les samedis soirs on se lâche et
pyjamas non sérieusement est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à faire un doigt d'honneur
comme chabat fait aux paparazzi et juste
pour vous donner une image d'un petit
peu rebelle je ne dis pas oui diesbach
est alors sans fondement
non
ap